vamos a practicar la identificación de
expresiones equivalentes tengo una
expresión escrita aquí en amarillo y
otras dos expresiones escritas en color
verde claro los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de encontrar cuál de
estas dos ecuaciones es equivalente a la
que está escrito en amarillo y es
posible que ninguna de éstas sea
equivalente suponiendo que ustedes ya lo
intentaron vamos a resolverlo juntos la
forma en que me gusta trabajarlo a mí es
simplificar todo lo más que se pueda
esta de aquí no está tan simplificada
vamos a distribuir este 2 y si lo hago
que me va a quedar
2 x menos 6 es menos 12 2 por 3 va a ser
igual a 6 y tenemos más 4 c podemos
simplificar lo más sumando los términos
que tienen a la variable menos 12 c y 4
c cuanto nos da menos 12 c + 4 c va a
ser igual a menos 8 c
estos los términos en azul cuando lo
sumo me duran menos 8 c y finalmente nos
queda el 6 al hacer esto tenemos
exactamente esta opción por lo que esta
definitivamente es una equivalencia a la
ecuación de aquí arriba y que acerca de
esta otra ecuación de aquí pues vamos a
simplificar la para descubrirlo
distribuimos el 33 por menos 4 c es
menos 12 c 3 por 2 positivo es más 6
tenemos más 4 c se ve bien y ahora
sumamos los términos que involucran a la
c menos 12 c y 4 c
sumamos estos dos y nos quedan menos 8 c
que es igual a estos otros dos así que
todas estas expresiones son equivalentes
esta ésta y aquélla hagamos otro ejemplo
y nuevamente pausa en el vídeo que
podrían ser las dos o podría ser ninguna
o podría ser una de ellas equivalente a
la ecuación de aquí arriba
vamos a hacerlo juntos y como la vez
anterior vamos a simplificar lo más que
se pueda lo primero que quiere hacer mi
cerebro es agrupar los términos que
tienen a la n y sumar los -6 de algo en
este caso ese algo es n + 4 de ese algo
4 n menos 6 n más 4 n nos va a dar menos
2 n sumamos los coeficientes menos seis
más 4 es menos 2 n y tenemos más 12
negativo que es lo mismo que tener menos
12 aquí simplificamos nuestra expresión
original
veamos estas de acá abajo si distribuyó
el 4
tenemos cuatro veces n 4 n 4 x menos 3
nos da menos 12 y ahora vamos a restar 6
n
- 6 cn y sumamos todos los términos que
tienen n 4 n y menos 6 n
nos va a dar menos 2n y agregamos aquí
el menos 12 y esa expresión a
simplificar la vemos que es equivalente
a la expresión de aquí arriba así que
estas dos son equivalentes vamos a
marcar las
ahora veamos la última vamos a
distribuir este 22 por 12 n es 4 n
y 2 x menos 6 es menos 12
esto se simplifica como 4 n 12 que es
obviamente diferente a menos 2 n - 12
así que esta no es equivalente a las
otras expresiones